[MUSIC]
The makers, the dreamers, the scientists,
the artists, the researchers,
the engineers,
the challengers,
the game-changers, the fearless.
>> Today, we work.
>> The myth debunkers, securers of
cyberspace and drivers of the driverless.
The climate leaders,
the energy shapers and
front-liners of artificial intelligence.
>> Today, we work.
[MUSIC]
>> The founders of new fields.
The bosses of brain science,
the smarts behind smart cities,
the industry disruptors,
pioneers of planetary robotics and
architects of what's next.
[MUSIC]
>> Today, we live it.
>> Breathe it.
>> Love it.
>> Write it.
>> Rewrite it.
>> Nail it.
>> We hack.
>> Attack.
>> Move.
>> Groove.
>> Start-up.
>> Start over.
>> Tinker.
>> Imagine.
>> And dare.
>> Today, we work.
[MUSIC]